Paige this is about your dad I mean him
getting out and coming to live with me
has made it clear that every choice I've
ever made was really because I've never
dealt yeah you're right it's maybe a
little bit about my dad
[Music]
how's work going oh man
I don't need you to tingle up what I got
going on and it wasn't right but it was
right you know appreciate you having my
bags huh I thought you Grandpa
to involve my son in these lies that got
me a new job I don't know if it's gonna
work out can't you just trust me you
don't know what this job is going to
work out trust doesn't work like that
you have to better be someone who's
never been before I think that you're
doing a great job and I don't say that
enough
I brought vodka I don't want her in my
house she just falls into the family
thank the Lord for all the mothers who
didn't get checks from the state and
still did a great job you're asking me
to do a TED Talk I mean think of how
many people you'd reach
I can't release this without photo ID I
need the birth certificate to get the ID
sir you need to calm down I'm calm come
on Master hello sir I need you to come
back when you get the ID
I don't know what to do
there we go one minute Miss Alexander
yes okay thank you
hey
life is messy
where are you are you okay it's not
about what you owe someone else it's
about who you want to be
oh this is good it is
laughs
[Music]